emmanuel and diana betchika have lost a
close relative in the pandemic
but diana's grandfather did not die from
covert 19.
last autumn he was admitted to hospital
because of his coronavirus infection
he was due to be released when a fire
broke out on the ward
killing him emmanuel and diana learned
of the tragedy from media reports
we were nervously sitting in front of
the television
we didn't know what was going on exactly
working with covert 19 patients in a
different hospital
she was scheduled to take her specialist
medical exam
the day after the blaze
i called my sister and told her listen i
worked very hard preparing for this exam
it's the most important exam in my life
but i don't want to find out tomorrow
morning whether or not my grandfather
died in the fire
so please tell me is he dead or alive
that way i'd have a few hours to process
the situation
then my sister told me he is dead
on the night of the fire 10 coveted 19
patients died in the intensive care
units
at the pietro nemts hospital in the
flames and toxic smoke
one medical expert thinks that the
ventilators for the intensive care
patients
could have overloaded the power grid but
hospital authorities
are still awaiting the results of the
investigation
the police sealed off both rooms were
not allowed inside
the investigation is still ongoing
there was thick smoke that made it
impossible to see anything
none of the patients were able to move
otherwise they would have fled
but they were too ill
the oxygen supplied that the patients
further fed the flames but it is unclear
whether or not
the blaze was actually caused by a short
circuit
and faulty wiring either way the medical
staff know the hospital equipment was in
poor condition
they tried using fire extinguishers to
beat back the blaze
but they had problems they were later
found to have been
faulty since then all the fire
extinguishers in the hospital have been
replaced
this wasn't the first fire in the
romanian covet 19 ward
in late january a fire broke out in an
intensive care unit in bucharest
here too the per state of the medical
facility
could be to blame staff say because the
heating didn't work
medics had installed electric radiators
in rooms with high levels of oxygen
an explosion then occurred here too the
investigation is still ongoing
vlad miksich a doctor and public health
expert with the european union
says it is highly likely the fires are
linked to the per state of romania's
hospitals
a large number of patients were being
treated in intensive care units
demand for oxygen was very high
hospitals with electrical systems from
the 1970s
simply cannot handle the amount of power
modern medical devices need
there was no political desire to invest
in hospitals
in the past decades decision makers have
not pushed for improvements
and now are suffering from the
consequences
over the past three months romania has
seen three new health ministers
the current minister confirms the
connection between hospital shortcomings
and the tragedies the fires are
connected to the state of the hospitals
and their poor infrastructure think the
main reason for this is political
instability
reforms need to be initiated and seen
through
regardless which government or minister
succeed one another becca is devastated
by the thought
that her colleagues lost patience due to
faulty equipment
i cannot believe it you go to hospitals
diana's family is suing the hospital but
she wants to keep working as a doctor
despite the shortcomings in romania's
i hope i can soon process this shock so
that i can devote myself fully to the
people in intensive care
they don't have any relatives by their
side and they're fighting for their
lives
like my grandfather did
the coronavirus pandemic has revealed
the dire state of romania's health
system
in a tragic way the country will need
years to bring it
up to date